aquí tenemos un prisma rectangular y nos
dan sus dimensiones el ancho es 2 la
profundidad de estrés y la altura la
representamos con una h y lo que vamos a
ver en este vídeo es como el volumen de
este prisma rectangular cambia conforme
cambiamos la altura dibujemos una tabla
aquí aquí pondremos nuestra altura y
aquí el volumen digamos que la altura es
5 qué valor tendrá el volumen pausa en
el vídeo y traten de calcularlo el
volumen va a ser la base por la altura
por la profundidad o también pueden
verlo como el área de este cuadrado
multiplicado por la altura la base por
la profundidad que 6 x la altura que
será 2 por 3 por 5 2 por 3 por 5 es 2
por 3 6 6 por 5 30 30 unidades cúbicas
suponemos que estas cantidades nos las
están dando en cierta unidad así que
tendremos las unidades al cubo ahora
pensemos qué sucede si duplicamos la
altura que ocurrirá con nuestro volumen
si duplicamos la altura
nuestra altura será 10 cuánto será el
volumen pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcularlo por su cuenta
en este caso seguiremos teniendo 2 x 3 x
nuestra nueva altura 10 por lo que ahora
tendremos 6 x 10 que es igual a 60 noten
que se duplicó nuestro volumen conforme
duplicamos nuestra altura así que cuando
duplicamos una dimensión vamos a
duplicar el volumen
veamos si esto se sigue cumpliendo
volvamos a duplicar esta altura que
sucederá cuando nuestra altura es igual
a 20 pues nuestro volumen será 2 por 3
por 20 2 por 3 por 20 que es igual a 6
por 20 120
nuevamente si duplicamos una de las
dimensiones en este caso la altura se
duplicará el volumen y también pueden
ver lo de la otra manera si pasamos de
2010 es decir dividimos a la mitad el
valor de la altura o una de las
dimensiones va a disminuir a la mitad el
volumen pasaremos de 120 a cc
ahora pensemos en algo interesante
veamos qué sucede si duplicamos dos de
las dimensiones sabemos que si tenemos
una situación voy a dibujar esto rápido
en donde tenemos dos por tres y la
altura de cinco
sabemos que el volumen es 30 30 unidades
cúbicas pero ahora dupliquemos dos de
las dimensiones esto ahora será un 10 y
esto será un 4 y este objeto lucirá
ahora así este es un 4 éste sigue siendo
un 3 y este ahora es un 10 va a lucir
algo así aunque no lo he dibujado
perfectamente a escala pero espero que
con esto se den una idea esto es 10
ahora cuál será el volumen pausa en el
vídeo y traten de calcularlo por su
cuenta 4 por 3 es 12 y 12 por 10 va a
ser 120 así que noten que cuando
duplicamos dos de las dimensiones vamos
a cuadruplicar el volumen pausa en el
vídeo y piensen por qué
esto sí duplicamos una dimensión
duplicamos el volumen pero en este caso
duplicamos una dimensión y después
duplicamos otra dimensión por lo que
multiplicamos por dos dos veces ahora
piensen qué sucede si duplicamos todas
las dimensiones cuánto se incrementará
el volumen pausa en el vídeo y traten de
calcularlo por su cuenta en general si
duplicamos todas las dimensiones que le
pasará al volumen